philanthropist can use resources beyond
just giving away money and the
importance of the personal leadership of
the philanthropist in actually
organizing people and making change and
the importance of mission related
investments of foundations using their
endowment funds to invest not just in
the stock market or international
securities but actually to invest in
profitable enterprises that are helping
achieve social missions that are helping
further their charitable objectives and
we see a real growth in foundations
beginning to use these practices in the
United States just over the last five
years the amount of foundation endowment
dollars has more than tripled that's
going into these mission related
investments and it's a tremendous
opportunity so many of the social
problems we look at are actually
economic issues you know whether it's
affordable housing whether it's poverty
and employment whether it's health care
these are frankly business issues and if
we're trying to work only through the
nonprofit sector I don't believe we can
solve them and so there really are
business opportunities and investment
opportunities in profitable enterprises
that can help address social issues and
that's a very important
I find stone tropic leadership first and
foremost as the idea of actually solving
a problem of thinking not about giving
away money but of taking responsibility
for the different elements that need to
be in place to create a solution I also
think a philanthropic leadership as
involving real personal commitment of
time and energy this is not something
that can be delegated to others and most
people who have the wealth to be
significant philanthropists also have
the clout and the network and the
expertise and intelligence to be
tremendously impactful players on the
issue and they need to bring their own
leadership to bear their personal
leadership to make things happen on this
issue I talked earlier about Tom Siebel
and his meth campaign in Montana well
once he demonstrated its effectiveness
he went to Congress and he personally
met with more than a hundred congressmen
to try and get federal funding for meth
campaigns around the country he has gone
to talk to other donors he's gone to
talk to other state governors and state
legislators to get this campaign spread
to other states and it's his network
it's his high-profile it's his
leadership that has helped get things
done there's probably no better example
than Bill and Melinda Gates of really
having changed how people think about
philanthropy and having revolutionized
how people think about neglected
diseases there are so many diseases in
the world for which we know the cure and
in some cases it would cost a dollar to
save someone's life and yet we're not
doing it and we're not doing it because
those people don't really have a voice
they don't have a political voice they
don't have an economic voice but gates
really single-handedly has focused
attention on a lot of these neglected
diseases and brought not just his money
but really tremendous flows of capital
from other sources and tremendous flows
of innovation and creativity to address
these issues so the leadership peas the
Jesus MRI stands for mission related
investment and it is it applies to
foundation typically it's used by
foundations could be used by
corporations as well but it's making an
investment where your goal is both a
financial return and a social outcome or
a social benefit and there are a lot of
opportunities to do it there are really
three ways of thinking about mission
related investments the most obvious one
that people often think about is
screened portfolios of stocks so you can
say I don't want any tobacco companies
in my portfolio and that's a negative
screen or you can say I want companies
that provide alternative energy and
that's a positive screen and that's one
useful way to think about it probably
more powerful is to think about actually
putting money into enterprises whether
it's housing projects whether it's
inner-city economic development whether
it's venture capital funds that might be
focusing on drugs for neglected diseases
but putting money in to help start and
grow enterprises that are actually
delivering social benefit and there's a
growing market for these things at a
growing opportunity for foundations and
individuals to make these kinds of
investor
bye